you guys may have seen this video that's
making the rounds this week online
Microsoft is coming out with something
called the hololens and if basically to
me pretty much means that the matrix is
happening let's take a look what if we
could go beyond the screen where your
digital world is blended with your real
world now we can this is the world with
Holograms
what will they enable us to do
new ways to visualize our work I have an
idea for the fuel tank
new ways to share ideas with each other
how things going your rent I just put
the images in onedrive more immersive
ways to play
new ways to teach and learn so put the
new trap in the place of the old one and
tights in here and yeah you can call me
neo because we are on our way to being
in the matrix I love these kinds of
stories I love this technology stuff we
do a lot of stuff on the bad side of
Technology and we're gonna do some stuff
on that later but this is all cool right
like when you were watching this did you
feel like wow the future is actually
kind of cool wait until I see it I think
that that's I don't know I'm scary you
think you're gonna take over no no no
I'm just really skeptical first of all
it's not gonna look like that like I've
done a lot of stories on holography yeah
and on kind of real-time rendering a
filmography
none of it looks that good yet all of
that was just computers did you guys see
gee I can say that's true none of that
was actual holography so right I think
that I just worried that they're trying
to sell us a product that's not going to
deliver nearly what that video says
right so you're saying at first it's
going to look more like jittery or look
like help me obi-wan you're my only hope
though before we get to the full color
for sure but that being said the the
technology it looks like is there it's
not gonna be quite as pretty it's not
gonna render the right way but the fact
that we're starting to have that
integrative technology it's really cool
I do wish they would have sold the
educational aspects of it a little bit
more right in that video this is just to
try to get us juiced up exactly like to
play Minecraft in our living rooms like
that was kind of sad that seemed sad
that guy doesn't get out much what do
you think I totally dig yeah I mean I
think it's awesome I first thought was
way to go Microsoft I mean it looks
amazing I think I mean obviously there's
always something lost in translation
between you know from concept to
production but
I mean virtual reality it's amazing
Google glass like they're stopping
production on it yes so what what
happened with Google glass because we
did literally probably 15 stories on it
everyone thought it was gonna be huge
I've only seen I mean we're in Los
Angeles here so we have a lot of early
adopters I've only seen one guy with it
and he was actually on a Segway too
which made him like the ultimate dork
I've ever seen probably probably
extremely dangerous but what happened
yeah I think Google glass was like
game boy of augmented reality it wasn't
really that functional you know added no
sort of value to users lives other than
looking really really dorky was awesome
yeah game boy was pretty great I
remember and I got my game was the game
gear a good reference that was the Sega
one thank you guys in the porn yeah
there will be great porn out there in
for me for this but really so you know I
joke about the matrix thing all the time
but like I really believe we're gonna
enter at some point we're gonna cross
some threshold here and I guess this is
sort of what rake rows walk occurs while
I was talking about with the singularity
like some point we're gonna just enter
this digital life and we're just gonna
be the batteries this whole operation in
some ways yes I mean I think that you
can there is a dystopian future that you
can kind of envision if you've ever seen
a black mirror yeah I just started
watching it this week I tweeted about it
last night there's an episode that's
basically this there's an episode well
there there's the grain episode but also
this reminds me of the episode and I
won't give anything away but where these
kids are basically in a big farm and
they're just on a bicycle all day
exercising and like playing these video
games to earn points and I think that
that's it's going to be a situation
where people are gonna have to find
balance between having a healthy and
nourished body and between living in a
digital world where you don't kind of
require a lot of the the environmental
and biological cues that you need in the
real world yeah I mean just like
recently I upgraded to the iPhone 6 I
know that you guys both have the iPhone
6 and I've noticed that my eyes are
starting to bother me at night baby
really because the screen is bigger
projects a lot more light and it doesn't
filter out the blue light at night which
we know disrupts the melatonin
production so it's like also really
really bad autocorrect on the like
making up words fixing things it's
actually making words one day that we're
actually gonna have to societies to like
parallel societies because it seems to
me that obviously only people that can
afford this stuff we're gonna get it
then you're gonna have people living in
this digital space and then you're gonna
have pretty much everyone else and I
know we already have the 1% in everybody
else but really we're gonna have like a
true digital do you I mean I think we
already do have a digital variety you
know something like
close to four billion people don't have
internet access I mean that's crazy to
think about that it's so integrated into
our lives now I don't know what I would
do without being able to use my GPS to
get somewhere without being able to just
you know Google something Wikipedia
something right away and the fact that
four billion people on this planet we're
close to it now don't have internet
access I think you're totally right and
we're just gonna see that digital divide
widen and widen yeah yeah the divide me
white but I feel like the rising tide
lifts all ships you know like the
average person in in sub-saharan Africa
has better cell phone technology in the
present at fifty years ago or some crazy
style like so yes I mean I remain
optimistic yeah yeah do you guys think
that we're gonna need at some point to
actually get away from some of this
stuff because it's because actually that
episode of Black Mirror which was pretty
fantastic more link to it in the we'll
link to it in the description right down
there that there was the whole point of
it was sort of was that they were losing
something at the same time that the more
we go with this digital stuff that we're
losing saying very human yes that's a
common trope in like TV shows and movies
that use digital technology as a plot
point is this kind of disconnect to
reconnect theme which I think we all
have to do periodically to kind of take
stock of where we are in our lives to
reconnect to our families and our
friends and things like that and
actually look people straight in the
face instead of through a screen alright
I'm looking at you in the face although
it is through pretty good what do you
think which side of the digital divide
are you on let us know in the comments
right down below and don't forget to
subscribe